would i get married again oh absolutely
if you don't believe in love what's the
point of living
hi diane lewis i own this pothole ron
swanson
and i'm here to fix it oh seaweed choke
that large boy is my colleague we work
at the parks department oh you're not
even from the public works department
look it appeared that no one from the
proper channels was gonna fix this
so i decided to do it myself do you know
what you're doing
yes ma'am yes i do
lemonade please and thank you hey i'm
sorry if i was current earlier
i'm a single mom and sometimes things
get chaotic around here and when you
shut up from the parks department no
need to apologize i understand
completely
this is delicious well i got it from
food and stuff so
that's where i got these gloves right so
how exactly are you gonna fix this hole
just for my own edification
uh i dug the loose gravel out of the
hole
now i'm using a jackhammer to remove the
larger pieces
then i'll spray down the hole to settle
the dust and fill it with cold patch
asphalt well thank you now i can fix the
next one myself
and diane sitting in a tree
k-i-s-s-i-s-s-i-p-p-i
do you hear that bird if you're here to
complain about the pothole i guarantee i
did it correctly actually i'm here to
ask you out for dinner
really well i hope you're not the kind
of man who needs to ask the lady out
i'm a middle school vice principal i
don't screw around does that freak you
out
no on the contrary so dinner
please and thank you well it'll be
casual no need to wear makeup
i begrudgingly admit that the 3-1-1
program
is a moderate success i'm still not sure
why the
citizen decided to come speak with me in
person
but i'm just happy to see a government
program finally work
hello diane i have brought you flowers
also chocolates and some grout cleaner
i noticed you needed grout cleaner so i
brought that too
very romantic my kids are non-negotiable
ron
it's a package deal i know i'm sorry
diane i really am i've been alone most
of my life by choice
and kids
this is all new for me but i'd like to
become familiar with it
if you give me a chance to prove myself
hmm your shoes are red now
yay hooray hey
mommy you survived huh indeed i did
how were they really couldn't have been
better
we had a wonderful time oh that's good
cause my sitter is still out of town
so i really hate to ask you this but is
there any way that you could take him
again tomorrow
no of course i'd be delighted you're a
lifesaver
thank you girls you want to spend
another day with ron yeah yeah
you need to fix this it's not that bad
nobody got hurt
it's extremely bad i love this woman and
i just want to show her that i'm capable
of watching her children
without something horrible happening
what
did you just say you love diane no
i did not yes you did that is so cute
for god's sake hansen will you please
focus on the larger problems
girls girls i don't know what you think
you heard but please
don't tell your mother what you
incorrectly think you heard
loves mommy
i love nothing first of all
everyone is fine no one got hurt but
there was
an incident oh my god what happened
ah diane this is all my fault i let them
go into my nurse's bag
who has been having fun with scissors
and taught us how to be doctor
yay you're not mad that's fine they're
kids
once zoey put ivy on the dryer so i'm
still incredibly sorry
i feel like i let you down it is so
sweet to me how much you care
this is why i love you oh
well i love you too
if you would like to visit europe i like
you so much i'd be willing to risk it
but not france right god no
see you know me pretty well already but
you're about to get to know me
even better i brought you here because i
want to show you something
that almost no one knows about certainly
not tammy
and not even leslie knope ladies and
gentlemen
and especially the ladies put your hands
together for the one
the only my man mr duke silva
a mighty fine holiday evening to you all
it might be cold outside but it's about
to get warm all up in my jazz
i of course i'm duke silver and i would
like to dedicate this first song
to my duchess
[Music]
you're so lucky
i'm going to kill you
so i uh am pregnant
i see i don't understand how we were so
careful
i warned you about this standard birth
control methods aren't usually effective
against a swanson
i got about a million thoughts running
around my head but i really just want to
know what you're thinking
okay here's what i'm thinking
i was gonna wait until our anniversary
take you somewhere romantic
perhaps in a canoe most likely in a
canoe
i actually built a canoe for that
purpose but given the news
and given my significant
feelings for you now seems as good a
time as any
ron swanson diane lewis
will you marry me yes
on one condition anything my love ask me
for anything in the world and i'll give
it to you
except a destination wedding just the
opposite
we'd both be married before i don't want
anything big or elaborate
in fact the smaller the better i assume
you can deal with that
are you kidding as far as i'm concerned
we could go up to the fourth floor right
now
wow hello there hey leslie what's with
the get up we're coming back from
cleaning up a pawnee river there's
nothing i love
more than squeegeeing slime off a
highway underpass where are you guys
going
the fourth floor getting married
okey-dokey well catch you later
what what what tattoos
what are you dead
you look like you're in rictus i just
i'm having so many thoughts and feelings
that i'm
paralyzed right now would you ladies
like to come can i be the best man
why not let's go ron is getting married
and i love him and i care about him and
this is the greatest day ever and i
i do not have time to talk about this
what
that's good if you would just slow down
a little then i could arrange balloons
or a flower cake or a bouncy castle or
something ah
ethel beavers we would like a marriage
license please and thank you what's the
date of the wedding
today it's a bit unusual but we don't
care
leslie knope would you please be my
matron of honor
diane you have no idea
what that means to me she gets it let's
go well this is like a waking nightmare
of happiness um i need to get some
flowers uh why don't you hold this
colorful
bouquet of highlighters rice i i need to
find some rice i need to throw some rice
why is there no rice in this municipal
government building i found a justice
guy these are the marrying people this
is carl hello carl my fiance and i would
like to get married right now right here
haven't i done a quickie wedding for you
before
it's certainly possible but this one's
going to stick i need your full names
for the license
ronald ulysses swanson diane tammy lewis
tammy you're middle name i'm kidding
it's elizabeth
let's go carl hey let's pump the brakes
carl okay belay that order carl
shortest possible ceremony i'm tired of
not being married to this woman do you
ron swanson yeah take down
and to be your wife i certainly do and
are you diane
yes yes i do she said yes okay are the
power vested in me before you carl just
one second
i would just like to give a short speech
if i may you have 10 seconds
at first glance it may seem as though
ron swanson and i have nothing in common
but webster's dictionary defines friend
thank you leslie
i could tell where you were going with
that it was going to be beautiful i now
pronounce you
man and wife
yay great job everyone the reception
will be held in each of our individual
houses alone pretend this is rice
you